I like to write down all of my lines
over and
hello everyone where are Sam and Nico I
have something very important to tell
you would you come with me please
probably have something to do with our
new smart TV app don't spoil it Sam got
that
Steve I want you to see this I flew in
from Texas so that I could show Sam and
Nico
up there with the big boy a new platform
we now have Smart TV applications for
corridor digital so this means I can
just turn on my big screen TV and it'll
automatically go there yes wow this is
like having our own TV channel God I
would have brought my popcorn had I
known this was going to happen is this
surprisingly better than everything else
say you just want to browse our shows we
got the entire react series here
including but not limited to all of the
extended reacts son of a dungeon torto
crew Channel say you're a crew cuts guy
or gal well boom there they all are wow
Markiplier versus donkey is a very good
video it is it's hard to take in how
much stuff we've made how many videos
does Corridor Digital now have I don't
know Steve but they're all on this
platform it's insane you know somebody
should pay you guys to do this if you
wanted to pay us to make more of this
you could go to Corridor Digital and
sign up don't donate buy the product get
the service yeah you know it's not even
a donation we're giving it right back
the best way to support us is to
subscribe to Corridor digital.com com
all of our shows ad free 15 off of all
of our merch tutorials series Like Son
of a dungeon all for the low low price
of 3.99 that's right we have it on Apple
TV Android TV Samsung and Fire TV and
coming soon to Roku and LG if you
haven't signed up for a membership to
Corridor Digital yet now is a great time
foreign